[Aplausos]
indignación en las calles de la capital
francesa aquí en París pero también en
burdeos estrasburgo ogán miles de
manifestantes se reunieron una vez más
para expresar su ira protestaron después
de que el gobierno forzara su
controvertida reforma de las pensiones
sin el voto de la cámara baja del
parlamento
es una vergüenza el gobierno no solo no
tiene la mayoría en la calle porque los
franceses Están en contra de la Reforma
sino que tampoco tiene mayoría la
asamblea nacional así que utiliza el
49.3 cuando nos enteramos nuestra
reacción fue que simplemente no se nos
ha escuchado en París se produjeron
altercados la policía disparó gases
lacrimógenos y cargó contra los
manifestantes para dispersar a la
multitud en la Plaza de la Concordia
junto a estas protestas los trabajadores
han bloqueado lugares estratégicos como
parte de las huelgas en curso en todo el
país como en la mayor refinería de
Francia en normandía donde los empleados
han decidido ir más allá de la huelga y
paralizar las actividades durante el fin
de semana aquí cerca de notes este
depósito de petróleo también está
bloqueado
expresamos nuestro derecho
constitucional que es el derecho a la
huelga nuestra herramienta de trabajo
está parada y sí eso crea escasez puede
bloquear la economía pero si tenemos que
pasar por eso lo haremos no es un
problema
este fin de semana están previstas
nuevas manifestaciones en toda Francia y
los sindicatos han convocado una novena
jornada de paro nacional para el próximo
jueves